look one of the things about becoming an
entrepreneur or an entrepreneur you want
to move up right you're trying to really
move up and succeed in your game you're
gonna be hit by so many different things
you're gonna get in so many different
situations that you don't know how to
handle them that if you don't have any
kind of way to settle down your mental
and emotional state you won't know how
to handle it then you go back and you're
losing and have to shut down your
business right so one philosophy that a
lot of entrepreneurs have been picking
up is stoicism and in this episode I'm
going to give you a lot of the ways they
thought that can help you in the process
of you building your business so what
most people don't know about stoicism is
the fact that it got started by a guy
who was an entrepreneur that lost
everything and he had to figure out a
way to think better so he can re-engage
in rebuild this business this is Z know
back in the days around 303 BC his
business was you know he is shipwrecked
he loses everything he has a loss comes
back at that time the guy that everybody
was studying with Socrates he started
studying Socrates through Socrates a few
different philosophies or branching out
skepticism cynicism stoicism and Seneca
was kind of leading the stoicism and the
next thing you know all these other
names came from stoicism and the whole
idea about stoicism is really for
different things so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna explain to you what those are
and ten things that you as an
entrepreneur you as an entrepreneur can
pick up to think like them that helps
you continuously advance in business so
when you look at stoicism you're looking
at four ways of thinking one is make the
best use of your time Seneca once said
some periods of time or snatched from us
some are stolen and some simply seep
away yet the most shameful loss is the
lost due to carelessness so what is he
really talking about you know we so many
times you lose time not because of you
because something else happened to you
but the one part that you have to be
fully upset about is when you lose them
because you're being careless about your
own time and a lot of times that happens
for lack of preparation so that's number
one so the second one has been a mastery
of emotions a big part of business's
your emotions are going to be going nuts
that was my intro and I give it to you
right there are three Greek words that
Stoics follow one is apatheia freedom
from emotions number two is
axis which is state of tranquility where
your emotions become impenetrable and
last but not least says Auto Rocky's
which is your ability to maintain inner
freedom the whole idea is as you're
building whatever you're building you
have to figure out a way to control your
emotions because nothing I'm telling you
right now 90% of the things that you're
trying to do when you build a business
it happens out of nowhere you don't know
it's gonna be taking place to you if you
don't have control your emotions you
want to how to handle them number three
walk the path of virtue why is this
critical I had a guy talk to the other
day they call me while I was in Jamaica
I was doing this conference call and it
was part of other agency and he said
yeah this guy was doing this and he was
doing this and he was doing that this
got a lot of money back in the 80s and
the 90s what happened with this guy he
walked away from virtues lost everything
is facing 72 years in prison because he
started ripping people off and that
completely ruins the guy's momentum so
if you're walking the path of virtue you
eliminate start stops what the start
stops I'm starting I create momentum
boom I lose everything because I try to
take a shortcut I have to come back
again again I start I started
experiencing momentum I think about
taking another shortcut I come back
again every single time you go back and
forth but if you build your business
based on the right virtues right values
right principles you are continuously
compounding your momentum there you have
Anna last but not least a self mastery
so that'll lead me to the 10 points here
now for some of you don't want to take
this concept of stoicism deeper there's
four guys you gotta study what is you
know
Epictetus Marcus Aurelius Seneca there's
a lot of books you can study but I
suggest you go study these as
individuals you can study this course is
you can study meditations you can study
a lot of these books but those are the
main force those Stoics to study but so
those are some of the basic four things
I'm talking to you about but you can
read a lot about stoicism you'll also
hear about wisdom temperance justice
courage and a bunch of different things
but this is the basic foundation I
having said this I wanted to share with
you 10 ways Stoics think that helps you
as the co-executive entrepreneur
entrepreneur to better handle these
issues when they come up number one a
stoic looks at things from the stand of
worst case scenario they call it a
negative visualization what does this
mean they automatically go to worst-case
if I make this decision what is the
worst case that could take place well if
we
we could be out of business well unless
we have to adapt or yeah if we do this
we could be out of business well if we
don't do this what's gonna happen we'll
never be a competitor well guess what
let's just do it anyways because there's
a risk as a businessman anyways we'll be
out of business but they at least know
that if they make this risk there's a
10% chance they'll be out of business
they go immediately to a worst-case
scenario anticipation and what it does
is by far the biggest thing that it does
by far the biggest thing that it does it
lessens the impact you now sometimes
when you go to the doctor and the doctor
gives you shot and they'll say it's
gonna feel like dot dot dot so then you
get the shot it feels like what they
said you anticipated it and it didn't
hurt you because you kind of know what's
coming versus if they don't tell you
then you're like oh my gosh what was
that all about
you didn't anticipate it just like that
they like to go to negative
visualization worst case scenario then
they decide what they do they create all
these different audibles then they make
the decision number one worst case
scenario number two wealth versus
mastery earlier today I sent a tweet out
and the tweet said if your goal if your
main goal in life is to chase Millions
you will eventually slow down but if
your main goal in life is to chase
mastery and experience mastery you will
never slow down because there's no such
thing as slowing down right there's a
lot of people online that they get the
house they get the car they get the girl
and then all of sudden they slow down
there's a lot of guys that get the money
and they think life's gonna be so much
crazier and in all of us and they're
surprised and they're like oh my gosh I
thought it was gonna be a million times
better I slowed down now what is million
times better isn't the material things
what is a million times better is that
idea of mastery the way you process
things do what you look at the world in
a whole different way then everybody
else thinks about Seneca again once said
wealth is the slave of the wise but
master of the fool listen
master of the full meaning money
controls the fool who doesn't realize
money can be your slave you tell money
what to do not the other way around
Seneca was a rich man when he died he
wasn't a poor man but he understood he
told money what to do not the other way
around so number two is the idea
wealth versus mastery number three
avoiding judging their so lightly about
judging we all judge we judge all the
time oh my gosh look what he's wearing
look what she's wearing
look at the way he said this why did he
say that why did he say that the more
you can get in this state to say I
honestly have no idea what they went
through this a divorce takes place
immediately everybody wants to say it's
his fault
it's her fault no one knows what
happened you are not there 24/7 to see
what happened oh my gosh look at this
guy what took place with him in his
business and look at this guy
and what took place with them no one
knows what the whole ideas and all the
stories that took place so for them
because they avoid judging they don't
consume their brain thinking about
somebody else's reason for failing
because there are so much consumed about
trying to figure themselves out when you
judge you have to start thinking about
what other people did and why they
failed I don't have time for that I'm
trying to figure myself out they avoid
judging to the best of their abilities
number four rational logic perspective
in the world of business you have to
have emotions but you have to also
understand you know rational logic and
perspective what is emotions if you
don't constantly talk about the
emotional aspect of why you started your
company division the cause that lowers
your social capital you need a lot of
social capital social capital when bad
things happen you sit your group that
you said listen guys let me tell you why
we did this company did you forget about
it we built this company because we said
we can do XYZ better and we said we can
serve the clients better and I know
we're going through this right now but
let's not forget what we did look how
far we've come along we're making a
difference in people's lives that's
needed a lot of that is needed at times
but the leader the CEO the entrepreneur
the entrepreneur internally needs to
understand rational logic perspective
when you do that you make better
decisions sound decisions better
investments better technology you reason
better because everything is based on
data numbers predictive analytics trends
nothing gives about just oh my gosh I
feel good about it
here's $800,000 all I just like the guy
here's six million dollar investment no
no you have to come back to this by the
way VC folks money folks any of these
guys that give money in that world
private equity guys they're all rational
logic perspective is where they're at
that's a thought pattern of a stoic
number five less hate to your
competitors instead understanding
meaning when I was initially coming up
and my competitors were bashing me
non-stop I couldn't understand him I was
like how could you say such a thing
about what we're doing but the moment I
started studying a bit of stoicism I
started realizing I understand what
they're doing their number one job when
I wake up in the morning is to put me
out of business they need my market
share and I'm taking it away from them
once I understood this concept I stopped
being upset at them I fully understand
understood them our relationship
actually became better because I know
what they were trying to do very simple
relationship if that makes any sense to
you okay so number five you actually
understand your competitors better
number six will power this is kind of
strange on what Stoics will sometimes do
so for instance what they mean by
willpower is a stoic will sometimes
sacrifice something let's just say
you've already made your millions or you
made money and you can afford to go
first class or you can afford to do
certain things they will sometimes
sacrifice what they can afford to remind
them of what it was like to have nothing
because as you start making money you
start believing your own hype everybody
around you tells you how amazing you are
how special you are oh my gosh look at
you you're a genius you're doing so
great etc etc they will step away and
put themselves in situations to
sacrifice but they can easily afford to
remind them what it was like to have
nothing that produces the feeling of
gratitude they lead better they
appreciate what they have better and it
obviously ends up producing better
relationships and people stick around
with them long term okay so number seven
is stoic is driven by the freedom to
think for themselves right so as you're
building a business everyone gives you
an opinion you should do this you should
do that you should do that you should do
this you should do that you should do
this you everyone's telling you what to
do everybody all of a sudden becomes an
expert right it's like when you get
married everybody starts saying when he
doesn't have a kid we're gonna have a
kid when you should have a kid earlier
you should have a kid early you should
have a kid or you should have a kid
early so for me whenever somebody gets
married one of the first things I'll say
is I said listen just so you know your
in-laws and your in-laws are immediately
going to start saying we're gonna have a
kid and then if you don't have it for a
year or two they'll start saying your
stuff doesn't work in your stuff doesn't
work anticipated and
in the beginning and just tell them
we're not planning on having kids for a
few years even if you're planning on
having kids if that makes any sense so
if you get pregnant you got pregnant if
you don't get pregnant no one's putting
you to pressure they're right
anticipation they'd like to think for
themselves right Henry Thoreau once said
to a philosopher all news as it is
called is gossip and they who edit and
read it are old woman over T tomorrow
many and friends were watching this
there's a phrase they call Keskin ich if
you know what guess can eke means you
know exactly what this means like in the
Armenian community you would see you
know your auntie and your grandma they
would sit seven-year-olds there having
coffee oh did you hear what this person
said did you hear what that person
that's what this guy's trying to say and
we throw he's a philosopher the point is
you cannot consume too much bias content
let me explain I know people that only
watch Fox I know people that only watch
CNN one of the reasons why if you can
figure out a way to avoid watching the
news rather read it from a writer or
somebody that is unbiased sharing what
took place facts statements not the ones
they they add their own twist to it
right you watch Fox you know what
they're gonna say you watch CNN MSMEs
you know what they're gonna say Stoics
want to think for themselves and when
you have somebody saying it they're
adding their emotions into it rather I
have three news emails I read every
morning it's unbiased here what happened
with China this is what's going on with
Venezuela here's what happened with
Apple yesterday this is what happened
with such-and-such yesterday facts facts
facts facts facts facts facts no opinion
facts facts xxx right and that's what
you're taking and then you and I have
the opportunity to decipher between the
stats and say you know what I think this
I think that I'm good because you want
to think for yourself in the world of
business you have to figure out a way to
think for yourself because many times
you will make a decision that nobody
will support but you have access to all
the information and you are making that
decision if after making a decision
you're still consuming all the content
from other people that are naysayers you
are gonna backtrack you're not gonna
play office you'll be defensive you'll
be a little bit hesitant made your
decision I don't want to hear about it
we're moving on this is what we're doing
game game game let's go right that's
what it means by the
they were driven by freedom to think for
themselves poor number eight they're
overly protective of their environment I
mean when I say overly it's like overly
obsessive protective like get away from
me if you are negative I don't want to
hear any of it Epictetus once said above
all keep a close watch on this there you
are never so tied to your former
acquaintances and friends that you are
pulled down to their level if you don't
you will be ruined
you must choose whether to be loved by
these friends and remain the same person
or to become a better person at the cost
of those friends if you try to have it
both ways
you will neither make progress nor keep
what you once had very simple I mean
there's nothing complicated what he said
what he's trying to say is yeah I want
to go be successful but I still want to
party my friends yeah I want to go be an
entrepreneur quit my own business but I
still want to be my friends mice you
wish the party to get him and we drank
together I still want to kick it with
them but you understand we go way back
we're boys that's my girlfriend that's
my boo right there smile it's my people
writing but then I want to go be
successful they don't go together
they just don't which one do you want
you want a party
stay here you want to go here go here
now couple your friends may upset I also
want to go here and they're working just
as hard as you the one that has bad as
you that's a different story
what epictetus are saying you want to go
here but your friends are pulling your
back from not wanting to win weekend you
want to change the ways you think
because the old ways of thinking is not
gonna get you the life that you want you
got to cut one of them off and if you
don't cut this off you ain't gonna go
and get that distance of winning so you
have to anticipate that part and be
protective of your environment number
nine authenticity don't explain to what
they mean by authenticity you'll keep
hearing about phrases of you got to
model this person model his behavior
model behavior model this person's
behavior model this person that person
this person but if you model too much
you don't even know it you all of a
sudden imitate and if you imitate you
all of a sudden lose your own uniqueness
now some people model because they're
uncomfortable with their quirkiness with
their own like flaws like for me you
know how many times I say certain words
that you say Pat that's not proper
English I'm okay with it
but it's me I'll pass sometimes you say
the sentence and it's a run-on that's
okay I'm comfortable with it you
understand what point I'm trying to
that is my quirkiness that is my flaw
that is my issue I'm very okay with it
right but I'm not trying to model to
speak like somebody else if you were to
go out there and say what Pat speaks
like this person you wouldn't be able to
say because I don't know how to speak
like anybody else this is just the way I
talk you have to figure out a way to do
you you have to be authentic on how you
are accept your flaws accept your issues
accept the fact that you have quirks
differences don't make it something like
you try to avoid doing certain things
because what if somebody finds out about
your quirks
that's your signature to the world don't
let any of that stuff bother you right
authentic yourself number ten last but
not least adapt and move on Epictetus
once said if you are defeated once and
you tell yourself that you will overcome
it but carry on as before no in the end
you'll also be so ill and weakened that
eventually you won't even notice your
mistake and will begin to rationalize
your behavior okay so if you just hold
yourself Pat that sounded good I have no
clue what the hell he just said right
there let me explain to what he's trying
to say what he's trying to say is okay
so I did something I made a mistake but
I want to move on but I'm still clinging
to my old habits and ways that I tried
to solve the problem this way and I
faced another issues and I'm still
trying to solve in the method that I saw
before don't expect anything to improve
because you haven't yet adapted and
moved on adapting means I tried away it
didn't work I adapted made adjustments
have a different approach to it then I
advanced so you'll see a lot of people
that hit a wall right and then they'll
make a decision that didn't work that
wasn't a best decision they'll go down
and then they get to the same wall again
they make the same exact decision again
I keep falling back down and a wondering
why this doesn't work like so many
people for example say you are wired to
be an entrepreneur and you're a very
great entrepreneur you try four or five
times to become an entrepreneur it
doesn't work for you realize I'm gonna
do it again I'm gonna do it again I'm a
duty and that's fine maybe your
positioning is an intrapreneur you know
you try to go out there and reposition
yourself to do something you're not good
at and you keep fighting fighting
fighting you're not a damn thing you
have to understand what your strengths
are you have to understand what your
abilities are
the more you're playing to that the more
you can make adjustments but if you
don't make any adjustments and adapt
you'll keep going back and getting the
same results and nothing will nothing
will change and eventually hear this
phrase business just wasn't for me I
just couldn't do it I don't know if this
industry's for me I don't know if that
industry's for me I tried real estate I
tried that guy just I was talking to
right now
this guy's changed industries ten times
and every time he changed industries
good guy every time you change his
industry but it's the industry this
one's not for me
this is the one that's for me and then
again that doesn't one but but this is
the one for me but that's the one for me
it's not about Deathstorm for you
everything you do when you reach an
issue if you make the decisions the same
exact approach you took before nothing's
gonna change so you have to learn to
adapt and move on okay so a couple
things if you watch this today and
you're thinking Pat I want to go a
little bit deeper into this topic
there's two videos I want you to watch
one is twelve mistakes I made as an
entrepreneur this kind of covers with
you the challenges I face right what
things I went through if you haven't
watched a click on this one and the
other one is a mindset it's an interview
I did with Jordan Peterson that goes a
little bit deeper into why he thinks the
way he thinks it's not all about
politics and all this other stuff
why is he why you're the way the way he
is he'll help you think in a complete
different way there's a part of him
that's also stoic as well that's what
I'm saying Jordan Peterson so told
mistakes as an entrepreneur there Jordan
Peterson interview and if you want
today's PDF click on a link below in the
description to go get the PDF and look
at this entire thing for yourself and if
you haven't yet subscribe to the channel
click on the sub button take care
everybody thanks for watching bye bye